This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. All of us are surrounded by brands. Designer brands. Calvin Klein's obsession. Oh, the smell of it. A brand. Bargain Shopper brands. You're going to spend $20 every month on paper towels anyway.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我们所有人都被各种品牌包围着。设计师品牌。卡尔文·克莱因的香水。噢，那气味。一个品牌。精明购物者的品牌。反正你每个月都要花20美元买纸巾。
You're throwing your money away. The mini-share wows are for everything. For every day you get. Brands were seemingly every demographic slice among us. This is what I've no way to throw. Our Minecraft rapping paper! Hey! It's my Christmas!
你在白白浪费钱。迷你份额的惊叹号适用于一切。你得到的每一天。品牌似乎渗透在我们当中的每一个人口统计细分中。这就是我无法扔掉的东西。我们的我的世界说唱包装纸！嘿！这是我的圣诞节！
Have you ever stopped to ask how Brands influence you? Is it the slick advertising, the relatable characters, or the story? Lance Armstrong will go out there, you know, with the story of, I beat cancer. And I'm going to put on my gear, I'm going to put on that yellow bracelet. I had about 50 of them. Today on the show, we conclude our Money 2.0 series with two of our favorite conversations about the psychology of brands. How companies create a world view around the products they sell. And then get us to make those products a part of who we are this week on Hidden Brain.
你有没有停下来问过，品牌是如何影响你的？是精明的广告、有共鸣的角色，还是那个故事？兰斯·阿姆斯特朗会走出去，你知道的，带着这样一个故事：我战胜了癌症。我要穿上我的装备，我要戴上那个黄色手腕带。我大约有50个。今天的节目中，我们邀请了两位最喜爱的嘉宾，通过关于品牌心理学的对话，来结束我们的“金钱 2.0”系列。公司是如何围绕他们销售的产品创造一种世界观的。然后让我们将这些产品变成我们自我的一部分，本周在《隐藏的大脑》。
America's Read knows what it feels like to be an outsider, to be surrounded by strangers, and to have to figure out how to fit in. Today, he's a professor of marketing at the University of Pennsylvania. But when he was 17, he was the new kid, one of a handful of black students bused to a predominantly white school. He remembers his first day, getting on the bus with the other black kids from faraway neighborhoods. They were scared, but we didn't want to show any weakness so we kind of walled in and walked in with confidence, and I remember the world
阿米尔·雷德知道身处局外人行列是什么感觉，被陌生人包围，必须弄清楚如何融入其中。今天，他是宾夕法尼亚大学的市场营销学教授。但当他17岁时，他是那个新来的孩子，是少数几个被乘车送到以白人为主的学校的黑人学生之一。他记得第一天，和其他来自遥远街区的黑人孩子一起上车。他们很害怕，但我们不想表现出任何软弱，所以我们有点像走进去，带着自信走进去，我记得这个世界
stopping and everyone looking up and sort of saying, who are those guys? He wanted to be accepted, so he came up with a plan. He would become a social chameleon. I sort of settled on this idea that I would try to be what was almost like a boundary spanner, so I hung out with the nerds, I hung out with the jocks, I hung out with the musicians, I hung out with all different groups, and in that sort of social chameleon as I would sort of go from group to group, I would try to kind of fit in in a way that allowed me to have some kind of affiliation with that group. As he spent time with these different clicks, he noticed that each had its own set of badges, its own language.
停了下来，所有人都抬起头，仿佛在说，那些家伙是谁？他渴望被接受，于是他想出了一个计划。他要成为一个社交变色龙。我大致确定了这样一个想法：我会尽量成为一个类似于边界跨越者的人，所以我和书呆子混在一起，我和运动员混在一起，我和音乐家混在一起，我和所有不同的群体混在一起，在这种社交变色龙的过程中，我会从一个群体走到另一个群体，我会试图以某种方式融入其中，从而让我与该群体建立某种联系。当他和这些不同的圈子相处时，他注意到每个圈子都有自己的徽章，自己的语言。
And he realized that if he could speak that language, adopt those badges, he would start to blend in. So he started buying stuff. He started wearing the things the other kids wore. Adop those badges, he would start to blend in. So he started buying stuff. He started wearing the things the other kids wore. Often it was about shoes. With the athletes, he wore Nike's, with the musicians, Chuck Taylors. With the hip-hop kids, Adidas, but without the shoe laces. They were like costumes, only deeper.
他意识到，如果他能说那种语言，采用那些徽章，他就会开始融入其中。于是他开始买东西。他开始穿其他孩子穿的衣服。采用那些徽章，他就会开始融入其中。所以他开始买东西。他开始穿其他孩子穿的衣服。通常是关于鞋子的。和运动员在一起时，他穿耐克；和音乐家在一起时，穿匡威。和嘻哈少年在一起时，穿阿迪达斯，但不系鞋带。它们就像是戏服，只是更深奥。
A brand can communicate something. How you wear your pants can communicate something. The particular sort of portfolio of colors that you choose to adorn yourself with can communicate something. America's understood that personal brands are like flags. They tell the world who you are or who you want to be. They telegraph, I'm the smart kid, I'm the rich kid, I'm the athlete. They're a form of self-expression. A brand is so much more than a tagline or logo. It is more of a meaning system. And so a brand is kind of a promise to deliver on those values and to connect consumers who might have in their
一个品牌可以传达某些东西。你穿裤子的方式可以传达某些东西。你选择用来装扮自己的特定颜色组合可以传达某些东西。阿米尔理解，个人品牌就像旗帜。它们向世界表明你是谁，或者你想成为谁。它们发送电报：我是聪明的孩子，我是有钱的孩子，我是运动员。它们是一种自我表达的形式。一个品牌远不止是一个标语或标志。它更是一个意义系统。因此，品牌可以说是兑现这些价值观的承诺，并将那些在其
minds a sense of synchronicity with what they believe those values are. We'll talk more in the second half of our conversation about the psychology of brands and the link between brands and behavior, but I want to start by looking at some examples of what you're talking about, America's. There are people who say, look, brands don't matter, as you said, I just buy what's functional, and then there are people like these characters from the CBC TV show Kim's Convenience. What are you doing? Oh, these shoes don't play basketball.
脑海中对这些价值观有同步感的消费者联系起来。在我们的对话的后半部分，我们将更多地讨论品牌心理学以及品牌与行为之间的联系，但我首先想看一些关于你所讨论的内容的例子，阿米尔。有些人说，听凭品牌无关紧要，正如你所说，我只买实用性强的东西，然后还有像CBC电视剧《金氏便利店》里的这些角色。你们在干什么？哦，这些鞋子不打篮球。
They're basketball shoes. You can tell by the little man playing basketball on them. No, your shoes are basketball shoes. My shoes are collector's items. And I intend to keep them that way. Ah, it gets to be bad if you got some breeder juice on them, sneaks, huh? Get that breeder away from me.
它们是篮球鞋。你可以从鞋上那个打篮球的小人儿看出来。不，你的鞋是篮球鞋。我的鞋是收藏品。我打算让它们一直保持那样。啊，如果上面沾了点饲养员的汁液，那就糟糕了，运动鞋，哈？离我那个饲养员远点。
Get your shoes away from my special edition breeder. Dude, I'm not joking. These shoes, they're my legacy. Oh, I... So, talk to me, America's about what's going on here. How can a pair of shoes feel like a legacy? I think that it's very interesting, Shunker, because a pair of shoes, if positioned the right way, can encapsulate a story.
离我的特别版饲养员远点。老兄，我不是在开玩笑。这些鞋，它们是我的遗产。哦，我……所以，阿米尔，跟我谈谈这里发生了什么。一双鞋怎么能感觉像是一段遗产？我认为这非常有趣，香卡，因为如果定位得当，一双鞋可以封装一个故事。
And that story might be, for example, a story about success or a story about overcoming the odds or a story about being able to have a kind of level of greatness that you would not be able to have but for the shoes. And so when Michael Jordan puts his shoes out there, there is the idea that it's very clear, right? So it says be like Mike, what does that mean? It literally means that if I wear these shoes, I will sort of encapsulate some of that mystique because I am wearing the shoes as well. And so it's a very powerful way that a brand can tell a story that can connect with a person's
而这个故事可能是，例如，一个关于成功的故事，或者一个关于克服逆境的故事，或者一个关于能够拥有某种程度的伟大的故事，如果没有这双鞋，你是不可能拥有这种伟大的。所以当迈克尔·乔丹推出他的鞋子时，这里面有一个非常清晰的想法，对吧？所以它说“像迈克一样”，那是什么意思？字面意思就是，如果我穿这鞋，我就会吸收其中一些神秘感，因为我也穿着这鞋。因此，这是一个非常有力的方式，让品牌能够讲述一个故事，这个故事可以与个人或
or a consumer's sense of identity that can then create this sense of legacy that the individual and the clip was referring to. So when you think about brands in the way that you're describing them, not as tags or even as just as names or commercial, a way to sort of commercially identify a product, but really as stories, as narratives, how valuable are these stories commercially speaking? Oh, there, tremendously valuable.
消费者的身份认同感产生共鸣，从而创造出个体在片段中所提到的那种遗产感。因此，当你以你所描述的方式思考品牌时——不是作为标签，甚至不只是作为名称或商业用途、作为商业识别产品的途径，而是真正作为故事、作为叙事——从商业角度来看，这些故事有多大价值？哦，它们具有巨大的价值。
And the reason that they're valuable is because they create a kind of impervious connection that's hard to break if a consumer connects with a brand or a product in terms of an identity argument instead of an argument about how better the features are of the product compared to something else they could buy. Then what is happening is that there is an installation from the brand's competitive attacks because once a person believes that a brand is part of who they are, then asking them to go to another brand is essentially asking them to change who they are. And that is an incredibly powerful psychological gravitational pull that is really hard to overcome. And that value in terms of customer lifetime value is a real like economic entity because
它们之所以有价值，是因为它们创造了一种牢不可破的连接，这种连接很难被打破：如果消费者从身份认同的角度，而不是从产品功能比他们能买的其他东西好在哪里的角度，来与某个品牌或产品建立联系，那么接下来发生的事情是，它对来自竞争对手的攻击产生了一种免疫。因为一旦一个人相信某个品牌是他们自我的一部分，那么要求他们转向另一个品牌，本质上就是要求他们改变自己。这是一种极其强大的心理引力，真的很难克服。从客户终身价值的角度来看，这种价值是一个真正的经济实体，因为
it literally means that the person is going to be on board and be buying for a very long time and be willing to do your own marketing basically for free because they are advocates of the brand. They are what we refer to as brand evangelists because they are now willing to go out there and protect the brand. So that value is massive in terms of creating this type of connection that can last with consumers for a very long time. You've used a technique called social listening to study the fans of a very iconic brand, the tech company Apple. What is this technique and what do you observe among Apple fans? This technique called social listening
它字面上的意思是，这个人将会长期支持并持续购买，并且愿意基本上免费为你做你自己的营销，因为他们是该品牌的拥护者。他们就是我们所说的品牌布道者，因为他们现在愿意走出去保护这个品牌。因此，在建立这种能够与消费者持续很长时间的连接方面，这种价值是巨大的。你曾使用过一种叫做“社交聆听”的技术来研究一个极具标志性的品牌的粉丝，即科技公司苹果。这项技术是什么，你在苹果粉丝身上观察到了什么？这项技术叫做社交聆听
is a combination of artificial intelligence and machine learning, where we literally go out into the internet and we identify conversations that people are having online about brands. And what we particularly find with Apple is that there is a special unique kind of conversation quality that happens between very fiercely loyal Apple users. And they talk about the brand in a fascinating way.
它是人工智能和机器学习的结合，我们字面意思上进入互联网，找出人们在网上谈论品牌的对话。我们在苹果身上特别发现的是，在忠诚度极高的苹果用户之间，有一种特殊而独特的对话品质。他们以一种引人入胜的方式谈论这个品牌。
There is language about the brand that almost feels as if the individual consumer is talking about religion or politics. There's a kind of fierce, very powerful emotional way that consumers talk about the Apple brand. I'm going to be showing you all of the Apple products that I own. From old to new, everything that I own from Apple. Something else, poor shirt mode. Oh my God, I'm literally obsessed with poor
关于这个品牌的语言，几乎让人感觉个人消费者是在谈论宗教或政治。消费者谈论苹果品牌时，有一种激烈且极具力量的情感方式。我将向你们展示我拥有的所有苹果产品。从旧到新，我拥有的所有苹果产品。还有别的，糟糕的图表模式。哦天哪，我简直对糟糕的
chart mode. Just because I mentioned that I have an Apple tattoo in my arm and I wouldn't say I would get it again. I was 100% Apple obsessed. I would say 75% of the conversations that I had ended up talking about Apple. And so Apple has been very good at creating this kind of emotional connection such that consumers once they are on board, Apple can basically say, hey, we would like for you to buy a new charger, which is kind of absurd. But consumers are like, sure, I'll do that
图表模式着迷。仅仅因为我提到我在手臂上有个苹果纹身，而且我不会说我会再纹一次。我当时百分之百痴迷于苹果。我想说，我进行的对话中，有75%最后都聊到了苹果。因此，苹果非常擅长创造这种情感连接，以至于消费者一旦上钩，苹果基本上就可以说，嘿，我们希望你买一个新的充电器，这有点荒谬。但消费者会说，没问题，我会买的
because they are so bought in, whereas, you know, they could go to Android and they could not have to ever deal with buying new chargers, et cetera, et cetera, but they're willing to do it. They're willing to stand outside in the cold, shunker, in a line and wait for hours and hours and commiserate with fellow Apple Loyalists to get that shiny new thing in the box. They don't have to do that. There's something that is not rational about this. And it's reflected when we look at and analyze the text conversations that occur between these fiercely loyal Apple folks.
因为他们已经深信不疑，然而，你知道的，他们本可以转用安卓，那样就永远不必应付购买新充电器之类的事情了，但他们甘愿这么做。他们甘愿站在寒风中，香卡，排着长队，等上几个小时，和同甘共苦的苹果忠实信徒们一起，只为了拿到盒子里那个闪亮的新玩意儿。他们本不必这么做。这里面有些东西是不理性的。当我们审视并分析这些死忠苹果粉之间的文本对话时，这一点就得到了体现。
Now Apple fans might say they are not deluded about their gizmos. They might argue that Apple products are objectively better than other tech products. But America's point is that you see the same brand loyalty when two products are objectively identical. The example that I always use in my class is a very simple example of over-the-counter pharmaceuticals, the Wal-Mart or the Wal-Green's brand versus Tylenol, and the fact that you can have a product that is essentially identical in terms of its active ingredients, but yet one will cost 27% more in the store,
现在，苹果粉丝可能会说他们并没有对自己的小玩意儿产生幻觉。他们可能会辩称，苹果产品客观上比其他科技产品更好。但阿米尔的观点是，当两个产品客观上完全相同时，你也会看到同样的品牌忠诚度。我在课堂上经常举的一个非常简单的例子是，非处方药中，沃尔玛或沃尔格林的品牌与泰诺相比，你可以拥有一个在有效成分上本质上完全相同的产品，但在商店里其中一个要贵27%，
and people know that the Wal-Green's brand is the same thing as the Tylenol brand and that entire market for Tylenol actually shouldn't exist if people are rational. But what it says is there's something else above and beyond the features that has utility. You can also see the power of brand loyalty in sports. America has spent a lot of time analyzing fans of the Philadelphia Eagles football team. People like Patrick Muller, who demonstrated his commitment to the Eagles
人们知道沃尔格林的品牌和泰诺的品牌是一样的，如果人们是理性的，泰诺的整个市场其实根本就不应该存在。但这说明，在功能之外，还有其他东西具有实用性。你也能在体育运动中看到品牌忠诚度的力量。阿米尔花了很多时间分析费城老鹰橄榄球队的粉丝。比如帕特里克·穆勒这样的人，他通过一辆涂满球队吉祥物和标志的大型房车，展示了他对老鹰队的坚定支持。
with a massive RV, plastered with a team mascot and logo. Eagle one is Patrick Muller's $300,000 homage to his beloved Philadelphia Eagles. I'm sure there's not any Eagle fan that has been more to games than I have in the last six years. Since 2006, this eagle has nested
“老鹰一号”是帕特里克·穆勒为了向他挚爱的费城老鹰队致敬而花费30万美元打造的房车。我敢说，在过去六年里，没有哪个老鹰队球迷看的比赛比我还多。自2006年以来，这只老鹰已经驻扎在
at every single game home and away. Talk about this, America. How do people like Mueller go from being consumers of a product to effectively being ambassadors of the product? The Eagles are intricately connected with the city of Philadelphia, right? The scrappy, gritty city of Philadelphia,
每一场主客场比赛中。谈谈这个吧，阿米尔。像穆勒这样的人是如何从一个产品的消费者转变为该产品的实际大使的？老鹰队与费城这座城市紧密相连，对吧？那个百折不挠、坚韧不拔的费城，
the underdog Philadelphia, the blue collar, Philadelphia, and for Patrick, you know, living those values and going to those games and being there when the team is awful and wanting to like represent your city through the sport, through the Eagles is something that's a special kind of characteristic, especially in this city of those fans that are Philly sports fans. And so for Patrick, he essentially immersed himself into this identity and almost lost
那个处于劣势的费城，那个蓝领的费城，对帕特里克来说，你知道的，践行这些价值观，去观看那些比赛，在球队糟糕透顶时陪伴左右，想要通过这项运动、通过老鹰队来代表你的城市，这是一种非常特殊的特征，特别是在这些费城体育迷身上。因此，对帕特里克来说，他本质上将自己沉浸在这种身份认同中，几乎迷失了
himself. His identity, I would say, Shankar is completely fused with being an Eagles fan. He's literally taken this beautiful RV and he's gone to all of the games since 2006. I mean, think about, we gotta have a lot of time in your hands, but think about the commitment. Think about the loyalty to do this
自我。香卡，我要说的是，他的身份认同已经完全与作为一名老鹰队球迷融为一体了。他字面意思上买下了这辆漂亮的房车，自2006年以来观看了所有的比赛。我的意思是，想想看，你得有大量的闲暇时间，但想想这种执着。想想看，为了做到这一点而付出的忠诚度，为了塑造一个形象和奇观，以及费城老鹰队。如果你是一个品牌，你会想，天哪，我该如何，我该如何复制世上的穆勒们，对吧？我该如何让所有这些球迷如此兴奋，以至于他们会在身上纹身，我该如何让人做这种事，让他们成为我行走的广告牌，成为我一人一人的
and to create an image and a spectacle and the Philadelphia Eagles. If you're a brand, you're like, oh my God, how do I, how do I clone Mullers of the World, right? How do I get all these fans to get so excited that they'll put the tattoo on their body, they'll, how do I get people to do that to be my sort of walking billboard, my one man,
男女免费营销部门？这很美妙，因为它指出了这样一个事实：如果你能做到老鹰队所做的事，即在故事上保持一致和真实，你就能创造出这类粉丝，吸引他们并强化他们想要向他人表达的东西。因此，为老鹰队特许经营权和橄榄球队推广他，并将他推向
one woman marketing department for free? And this is beautiful because it points to the fact that if you can kind of do what the Eagles did with respect to keeping consistent and authentic with their story, you can create these types of fans, draw them in and reinforce what they want to try to express to others. And so promoting him and sort of bringing him
最前沿，是一件天才之举，因为你实际上只是在利用这样一个事实：你拥有一个铁杆布道者，他如此深陷于你的品牌之中，以至于他愿意做这些事情来代表你发声。因此，如果你有一些公司确实想从零开始创造这些品牌，从地面开始建立它们，很多公司现在当然认识到这是一件很有力量的事情，所以很多公司都想参与其中。这里有一个艾伦·德杰尼勒斯的片段，关于一家公司努力创造一个独特品牌的尝试。
to the forefront for the Eagles franchise and football team is a genius thing to do because you're literally just piggybacking on the fact that you've got a hard core evangelist that is so wrapped up in your brand that he's willing to do these things to advocate on your behalf. So if you have companies that actually want to create these brands from scratch to build them up from the ground, lots of companies now recognize, of course, that this is a powerful thing to do, so lots of companies want in on this. Here's a clip from Ellen DeGeneres about one company's efforts to create a distinctive
这是BIC笔公司推出的一款新产品，他们有一个名为“BIC for her”的新系列钢笔。这是完全真实的。它们是专为女士设计的钢笔。我知道你在想什么。真是该死的时候才来。我们的笔呢，伙计？你能相信吗？这些年来我们一直都在用男士笔。
brand. It's a new product from BIC, the Penn Company, and they have a new line of pens called BIC for her. And this is totally real. They're pens just for ladies. I know what you're thinking. It's about damn time. Where have our pens, man? Can you believe this? We've been using man pens, all these years.
是的。那么，是什么吸引了你，阿米尔？与苹果公司的产品相比，为什么这个广告活动会反响平平？答案是，当一家公司试图锁定特定身份认同以便建立连接、建立与其品牌相关的连接时。它必须以一种几乎是社会学的方式去理解这种身份认同。就“BIC for her”而言，
Yeah. So what have been drawn to your America? Why did this ad campaign fall flat compared to the stuff that Apple does? The answer is when a company is trying to hone in on a specific identity to make a connection, a relevant connection to its brand. It has to understand that identity in an almost sociological way. And in the case of Bick for her,
我认为很明显，性别与购买钢笔之间的相关性为零。因此，如果你试图讲这样一个故事，即这些是专为女性设计的钢笔，那么如果你没有立刻被赶出大楼，问题就会是：好吧，告诉我为什么是这些，为什么？为什么这些钢笔被称为“专为女性设计”？
I think it's quite clear that the correlation between gender and buying pins is zero. And so if you try to tell a story that says, and buying pins is zero. And so if you try to tell a story that says, these are the pins for women, then if you don't get immediately thrown out of the building, the question will be, okay, tell me why these, why? Why are these pins, quote, for women?
我认为就“BIC for her”这个具体案例而言，可以说是金玉其外，败絮其中，香卡。它只是一种被视为噱头的东西。顺便说一句，香卡，在营销和商业界，当我们不知道如何向女性营销时，我们称之为“缩小并涂成粉红色”。这就像是一个巨大的错误，因为你根本懒得去了解女性。这非常明显。
And I think in the specific case of Bick for her, there was nothing underneath the hood, so to speak, Shunker. It was just kind of like perceived as this gimmick. We call this, by the way, Shunker, in the marketing and business world, when you do not know how to market to women, we call it shrink it and pink it. And it's like, it's a huge mistake because you didn't bother to try to understand women. That's very clear.
事实上，你走向了反面，讲了一个几乎会被女性视为侮辱的故事，就身份认同而言，这就像让女权运动开倒车，因为人们会想，等一下，我们不需要专为女性设计的钢笔。正因为你不理解那种身份认同，而且你没有认真对待它，
And in fact, you went the opposite way in telling a story that would almost be perceived as insulting to women, like taking the feminist movement backwards in terms of identity because it's like, well, wait a minute, we don't need the pen for women. And so because you didn't understand that identity, and you didn't take it seriously,
你没有去研究它，你没有从社会学角度去剖析、分析它并试图理解它与那个特定决策过程的联系，你才会犯下像BIC所做的那样的愚蠢错误。我想花一点时间讨论一个非商业、非消费的场景。共和党人和民主党人不会把他们的政党当成品牌来看待，但听起来
you didn't study it, you didn't sociologically unpack it and analyze it and try to understand its connection to that specific decision-making process, you make dumb mistakes like how Big MADE. I wanna talk a moment about a non-business, non-consumer setting. Republicans and Democrats don't think about their political parties as brands, but it sounds
你没有去研究它，没有从社会学角度去解构、分析并试图理解它与那个特定决策过程的联系，你就会犯下像Big所犯的那些愚蠢错误。我想花一点时间谈谈一个非商业、非消费的场景。共和党人和民主党人并不认为他们的政党是品牌，但听起来
like they almost relate to them in the way people relate to brands. And I'm wondering is the animosity we see in the country between Republicans and Democrats less to do with ideology and more about brand loyalty? Political parties are indeed brands. And what we're witnessing today right now is the almost perverse extreme aspect of when identity and identity loyalty and identity connection goes way off the rails. And so the notion that political parties are now becoming tribes is very, very clear and making connections to their identity, right?
他们对待政党的方式几乎就像人们对待品牌一样。我想知道，我们在国内看到的共和党人和民主党人之间的敌意，与其说是意识形态问题，不如说是品牌忠诚度问题？政党确实就是品牌。我们今天乃至此刻所目睹的，是当身份认同、身份忠诚以及身份联结完全失控时，那种近乎变态的极端现象。因此，政党正在变成部落的这种观点非常、非常清晰，并且与他们的身份认同建立了联系，对吧？
So if you have a proposition to say, I would like to build a wall to help with immigration, you can make a functional argument about a wall. Or you can do what Republicans did, which is to make an identity argument to say that wall represents keeping some group of individuals out that we don't want in this country for lots of different reasons. That's an identity argument, that's an in-group out-group argument, that's an emotional argument, and so on. On the other side, the other side says this wall now represents something that is antithetical to how they see themselves. It represents oppression,
所以如果你提出一个主张，说我想建一堵墙来协助解决移民问题，你可以就这堵墙进行功能性的辩论。或者你可以做共和党人所做的事情，那就是提出一个身份认同的论点，声称这堵墙代表着把出于各种不同原因我们不希望留在国内的某类群体挡在外面。这是一个身份认同的论点，是一个内群体与外群体的论点，是一个情感论点，诸如此类。而在另一方看来，这堵墙现在代表着与他们自我认知相悖的东西。它代表着压迫、
discrimination, it represents all things evil. So there's no way to do can have a conversation about trying to settle on an issue on how to move forward with a policy around that wall because the wall now has become a symbol of identity. It's all about your tribe. It's all about the values that you are trying to protect, that you believe that you are trying to protect as they are encapsulated in your particular political brand. When we come back, what happens when your favorite brand breaks your heart? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain.
歧视，它代表着一切邪恶的事物。因此，根本无法就如何就围绕这堵墙的政策向前推进这一问题展开对话并达成一致，因为这堵墙现在已经成了身份认同的象征。这完全关乎你的部落。这完全关乎你试图保护的价值观，那些你认为自己正在努力保护、且被封装在你特定政治品牌中的价值观。广告回来后，当最喜欢的品牌让你心碎时会发生什么？你在收听的是《隐形的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐形的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedanta. When America's read was in his early 40s, a doctor told him that his knees were in bad shape. He needed to give up basket ball and running. So he started to look for another sport that would be easier on his joints. I got into cycling and found the sport and fell in love with the culture immediately. And like a lot of people, I connected with the Lance Armstrong brand. And actually Lance Armstrong plus Nike plus America's equaled, something that was so aspirational in my mind. Armstrong is a man who rides on courage and guts.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。当美洲红（America's read）四十出头时，一位医生告诉他，他的膝盖状况很糟糕。他需要放弃篮球和跑步。于是他开始寻找另一项对关节冲击较小的运动。“我迷上了骑行，找到了这项运动，并立刻爱上了这种文化。就像许多人一样，我与兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的品牌产生了共鸣。事实上，兰斯·阿姆斯特朗加上耐克再加上美洲红，在我心中等同于一种非常令人向往的东西。”阿姆斯特朗是一个凭勇气和毅力骑行的人。
If his team make concrete, Lance brought me into the world of professional cycling in terms of actually watching it, watching the tour de France. And I fell in love with Lance because his story, his story of I beat cancer and I'm going to put on my gear, I'm going to put on that yellow bracelet. I had about 50 of them. And the jersey, the shoe warmups, everything. And I would go, I bought the bike that he used. And I would be out there, and I would be channeling Lance Armstrong.
如果他的团队表现稳定，兰斯将我带入了职业自行车运动的世界，让我真正开始观看它，观看环法自行车赛。我爱上了兰斯，因为他的故事，他战胜癌症的故事，以及我要穿上我的装备，我要戴上那个黄色手腕带。我大约有50个。还有球衣、鞋套、各种装备。我会去买他用过的自行车。我会骑着车，仿佛我就是兰斯·阿姆斯特朗。
I would think about Lance Armstrong in the mountains. And it was for me deeply emotional. And when little whisperings came out that, well, wait a minute, people are accusing Lance Armstrong of cheating. I was the first to say, you're wrong. No way this is not happening. As just announced moments ago, it will ban Armstrong for life and strip him of his seven-tour title.
我会在山路上想象自己是兰斯·阿姆斯特朗。对我来说，这具有深厚的情感。当开始有一些小道消息传出，说什么等一下，人们在指责兰斯·阿姆斯特朗作弊时。我是第一个跳出来说，你们错了，绝不可能发生这种事。就在刚才宣布的消息，他将被终身禁赛，并剥夺他的七个环法冠军头衔。
And it was heartbreaking from the perspective of my identity because what happened was I lost a part of myself. And when it came out that Lance Armstrong is a fraud, Lance Armstrong is a charlatan. I literally remember the day that I went and got all of my live strong and Lance Armstrong gear, and I put it in a bag, and I set it outside.
从我身份认同的角度来看，这令人心碎，因为发生的事情是我失去了自我的一部分。当真相大白，爆出兰斯·阿姆斯特朗是个骗子、兰斯·阿姆斯特朗是个江湖骗子时。我甚至能清晰地记得那一天，我把所有的“力抗”（Livestrong）和兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的装备都拿出来，装进一个袋子里，然后扔在外面。
It was almost like a funeral, Shankar. It was like, it was a moment of grieving because this iconic aspirational self turned out to be a shallow and hollow fraud. And I felt foolish. I felt like I was a fool in that relationship with his brand because I was trying to reinforce and express all of these values that turned out
香卡，那感觉就像是一场葬礼。就像是一个悲伤的时刻，因为这个具有标志性的、催人奋进的自我最终变成了一个肤浅且空洞的骗子。我觉得自己很愚蠢。在这段与他的品牌的关系中，我感觉自己像个傻瓜，因为我曾试图强化和表达所有这些最终证明并不是真的价值观。
not to be true. It's so interesting isn't it? Because at one level, Landsom's strong doing well, him beating cancer, him winning the short of France, really has nothing to do with you and his cheating and his doping also has nothing to do with you. And yet you triumphed when he triumphed and you grieved when he fell. That's, you're touching on something I think is the key premise of identity connections between consumers and brands, Shunker. And that's the idea is that once my identity fused
这不是很耐人寻味吗？因为一方面，兰斯·阿姆斯特朗表现出色，他战胜了癌症，他赢得了环法自行车赛，实际上跟你没有任何关系；他的作弊和服药也跟你没有任何关系。然而，当他获胜时，你也随之欢欣鼓舞；当他跌入谷底时，你也感到悲痛。你触及了一点，我认为这是消费者与品牌之间身份认同连接的核心前提，香卡。这个想法就是，一旦我的身份与它融为一体，
with that, I was in sync with his highs and lows. And the idea that even though his performance, his approach had nothing to do with me, I was using that story, not only on the bike in a literal sense, but also kind of in my life, in a figurative sense, in the sense that I would almost think about mentally represent Lance on the bike when I was faced with a challenge in my professional life or in my personal life.
我就与他的高潮和低谷同频共振。尽管他的表现、他的方法与我毫无关系，但我一直在使用那个故事——不仅在自行车上是字面意思上的使用，而且在我的生活中也是比喻意义上的使用。当我在职业生涯或个人生活中面临挑战时，我甚至会在脑海中想象并代表自行车上的兰斯。
And I used that energy, that motivational impetus that's coming from the brand, that's haloing off the brand, that I'm consuming from the brand. I'm using that for me as a source of energy that allows me to push through, to soul-jirond, and all of those different values that are associated with, you know, the idea that, I'm putting in the work on the bike, I'm diligent, I believe, I believe in myself, I'm gonna work hard, and I'm gonna overcome great obstacles. And so, even though it had nothing to do with me,
我利用那种能量，那种来自品牌、由品牌散发光环、我从品牌中汲取的动力。我将其用作推动自己前进的能量来源，去苦干，去具备那些与以下观念相关的所有不同价值观：我在自行车上付出努力，我勤奋，我有信念，我相信我自己，我要努力工作，我要克服巨大的障碍。所以，尽管这与我毫无关系，
I was drawing upon that energy. And when I found out that the energy was actually poisoned, then it sort of resulted in this deep sense of loss for me. You conducted a study with Ameth Bhattacharji and Jonathan Burman, how he sometimes decoupled problematic aspects of a brand with the things that we admire about the brand. If Landsom strong had been caught stealing rather than doping, I'm wondering if you could have decoupled
我一直在汲取那股能量。当我发现这股能量其实是有毒的时，这自然就导致了我内心深处那种深切的失落感。你和阿米思·巴塔查吉（Ameth Bhattacharji）以及乔纳森·伯曼（Jonathan Burman）共同进行了一项研究，关于我们有时如何将一个有问题的问题品牌与我们所欣赏的品牌的某些方面剥离开来。如果兰斯·阿姆斯特朗被抓到的是偷窃而不是服药，我想知道你是否能够将
your admiration for Landsom strong the athlete with your distaste, was the fact that the unethical behavior was in the same domain as is accomplishment that made them difficult to disentangle? In the paper that you referenced there, we refer to this notion that you're talking about as moral decoupling. And so it's based on the fundamental premise that,
你对运动员兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的欣赏与你的厌恶分离开来？是因为不道德的行为与他的成就在同一个领域，才使得它们难以厘清吗？在你引用的那篇论文中，我们将你所讨论的这种概念称为“道德解耦”。所以它基于这样一个基本前提：
if there is an individual, that you have a natural inclination to want to support, then what we know about psychology is that humans will figure out ways to rationalize the support for that individual that they want to support to uphold the belief that they want to have. And so they will try to interpret the world around them in ways that allow them to uphold those beliefs. An example of this is the tale of Tiger Woods.
如果有一个人，你内心有着想要去支持他的天然倾向，那么根据我们对人类心理学的了解，人类会想方设法为他们想要支持的那个人合理化这种支持，以维护他们想要拥有的信念。因此，他们会试图以允许他们维护这些信念的方式来解读周围的世界。这方面的一个例子就是泰格·伍兹的故事。
At the end of 2009, he stepped back from the sport of golf after tabloids broke the news that he was having an affair. The golfing world was split between those who were appalled by his behavior and stopped supporting him and those who stuck by his side. If you look at his story, what did he do? Well, he cheated on his wife. And so cheating on your wife presumably
2009年底，在小报爆出他有婚外情的新闻后，他暂时退出了高尔夫球坛。高尔夫球界分裂为两派：一派对他的行为感到震惊并停止支持他，另一派则坚定地站在他身边。如果你看看他的故事，他做了什么？嗯，他背叛了他的妻子。所以背叛妻子按理说
has nothing to do with your golf game. So if you desired to support Tiger Woods, you could make the mental argument in your mind that would reflect moral decoupling. You could say, well, you know, I don't really agree with this whole thing that he might have been doing in his personal life. However, I really like his golf game. So I'm going to continue to support him. And so what's interesting about moral decoupling, if that bad thing that the celebrity or the person
跟你的高尔夫球技毫无关系。因此，如果你渴望支持泰格·伍兹，你可以在脑海中进行一番心理推演，从而体现出道德解耦。你可以说，嗯，你知道的，我其实并不同意他在个人生活中可能做的那些事。不过，我真的很喜欢他的高尔夫球技。所以我将继续支持他。所以关于道德解耦，有趣的地方在于，如果名人或这个人所做的坏事
does is not related to the performance that you admire, then you can pull it apart in your mind and you can almost ignore, if you will, or not even comment on the morality of the bad thing because you can simply focus on the performance and the fact that you admire what they do in that performance domain. And so it's a very interesting aspect because in the case of Lance Armstrong, it was impossible for me. And I'm going to tell you the truth. Lord knows I try.
与你所欣赏的表现无关，那么你就可以在脑海中将它们拆分开来，你几乎可以忽略——如果你愿意的话——甚至不去评论那件坏事的道德问题，因为你可以简单地专注于表现，以及你在那个表现领域中欣赏他们所做事迹这一事实。这是一个非常有趣的方面，因为就兰斯·阿姆斯特朗而言，对我来说这是不可能的。我要跟你说实话。苍天可鉴，我尝试过。
But it was impossible for me to pull those two things apart for Lance Armstrong. And that's why all of his clothes ended up on my sidewalk. So. Now, there are lots of people, America, who think that the idea of building a brand is just distasteful. It's just marketers and big companies trying to hoodwink customers, hoodwink consumers.
但对我来说，要将兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的这两件事分离开来是不可能的。这就是为什么他所有的衣服最后都落在了我的人行道上。所以。现在，有很多人，阿米尔，认为建立品牌的想法简直令人反感。这不过是营销人员和大公司试图欺骗顾客、欺骗消费者罢了。
Frank, German, Aaron Garvey and Lisa Bolton once conducted an interesting study involving Nike putters. And when I spoke with Frank, German, here's how he explained the study to me. About half of the participants were told that they would be putting with a Nike putter, whereas the other half of participants were not told what putter brand they would be using. Importantly, all participants used the exact same putter. And interestingly, our results showed that those who thought that it was a Nike putter on average needed significantly fewer putts to sink the golf ball.
弗兰克·日耳曼（Frank German）、亚伦·加维（Aaron Garvey）和莉萨·博尔顿（Lisa Bolton）曾经做过一项有趣的关于耐克推杆的研究。当我与弗兰克·日耳曼交谈时，他是这样向我解释这项研究的：大约一半的参与者被告知他们将使用耐克推杆进行推击，而另一半参与者则没有被告知他们将使用什么品牌的推杆。重要的是，所有参与者使用的完全是同一根推杆。有趣的是，我们的结果显示，那些认为自己使用的是耐克推杆的人，平均需要的推击次数明显更少，就能将高尔夫球击入洞中。
What's going on here, America? In some ways, this is connected to what you were telling me about wearing your Landsaham strong gear and biking and feeling like you were doing better, but this actually suggests this isn't just a feeling you actually might have biked better when you are wearing your Landsaham strong gear. What it literally shows is the placebo effect, which is what they are really tapping into here, is real. You have been told about just do it for so long. You believe that that brand endows a performance advantage. So much so that the psychological perceptions of that brand
这里发生了什么，阿米尔？在某种程度上，这与你之前跟我说的关于穿着兰斯·阿姆斯特朗装备骑车并感觉自己表现更好的经历有关，但这实际上表明这不仅仅是一种感觉，当你穿着兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的装备时，你可能真的骑得更好。这字面意思上展示了安慰剂效应，他们在这里真正触及的正是这一点，它是真实存在的。你被灌输“Just Do It”这句话太久了。你相信那个品牌赋予了你性能优势。以至于对那个品牌的心理感知
literally translate in your ability to actually perform, to make those put puts in fewer strokes. And that to me is the most salient and powerful example of this notion that the power of brand is so intertwined with the perceived expectations of the behavioral activities that are built into that narrative or that story about the brand that they literally translate into advantages for the brand that really shouldn't be there
字面意思上转化为你实际表现的能力，让你用更少的杆数完成推击。对我来说，这是最显著、最有力的例子，证明了这样一个概念：品牌的力道与关于该品牌的叙事或故事中内置的行为活动的预期高度交织在一起，以至于它们字面意思上转化为该品牌本不应该具备的优势，
for all intents and purposes. I wish someone would have put the metrics on me and done the controlled experiment where I didn't know it double-blind or I would be on my bike with and without the land's Armstrong close and see because I would be on my bike with and without the Lance Armstrong clothes. And see, because I would be willing to bet. I remember days going out and riding the bike. I remember this one time where I was trying to go up this one hill and I was struggling. I looked down and I could see my live strong band on my wrist and look down and I unzipped my bike jersey like Lance does.
不管从什么角度来看都是如此。我希望有人能在我的身上测量各项指标，并做一个对照实验，采用双盲法，让我分别在穿着和不穿着兰斯·阿姆斯特朗服装的情况下骑车，看看结果如何，因为我敢打赌。我记得有几天出去骑车。我记得有一次，我试图骑上一座山，觉得很吃力。我低头一看，可以看到手腕上的“力抗”手腕带，再低头看，我像兰斯那样拉开了骑行服的拉链。
This is something Lance used to do when he was about to get serious. He would unzip his jersey and take his cap and he flip it around. And he's like, this means that he's signaling to his competitors. I'm about to get very, very hardcore into this and I'm about to take it to a whole new level. I remember doing that and I remember powering through this hill and getting to the top and imagining in my mind those fans of Lance that would be at the top of the hill cheering him on and I almost I'm willing to bet that my performance improved when I was wearing his gear.
这是兰斯准备认真起来时常做的一个动作。他会拉开骑行服的拉链，把帽子转到后面。这就像是他在向竞争对手发出信号：我要开始全力以赴了，我要把这件事提升到一个全新的水平。我记得我当时那样做了，我记得自己充满力量地冲上了这座山，到达了顶峰，并在脑海中想象那些在山顶为兰斯欢呼的粉丝，我几乎可以打赌，当我穿着他的装备时，我的表现确实提升了。
You've talked in the past about how branding can be a force for good, that it can help companies that are mission-driven companies accomplish great things. But I'm wondering if you can also talk a little bit about this challenge that branding has. A lot of people see it as manipulative, see it as inauthentic. Does branding have a branding problem? That's fantastic. I love that question, Schumger.
你过去曾谈到过品牌塑造如何能够成为一股向善的力量，它如何能够帮助那些有使命驱动的公司成就伟大的事情。但我想知道你是否也能稍微谈谈品牌塑造面临的这一挑战。很多人认为它是操纵性的、是不真实的。品牌塑造是不是自身也存在“品牌问题”？太棒了。我喜欢这个问题，香卡。
The answer is yes. And it's unfortunate because branding in and of itself is neither inherently good or bad. So it's kind of like the analogy that I like to use what I'm talking about this is that branding and marketing more generally is like a hammer. And so, you can take a hammer, and if you want to, you can build a house for a homeless person, right? But you can also take a hammer,
答案是肯定的。这很不幸，因为品牌塑造本身既不是生来就好，也不是生来就坏。所以这有点像我谈论这个时喜欢用的比喻：品牌塑造和更广泛的营销就像是一把锤子。所以，你可以拿着一把锤子，如果你愿意，你可以为无家可归的人建造一座房子，对吧？但你也可以拿着一把锤子，
and if you want to knock an elderly person upside their head and take their wallet. There's nothing inherently bad about a hammer. It's how you use it, and why not use it as a force for change as something powerful and positive. For example, if you are a brand that is a sports company, isn't it great that you can actually become the motivational impetus for a consumer to want to exercise more and to make themselves healthier for themselves and their loved ones? Isn't that a good thing? I think that's a good thing.
如果你想的话，也可以朝一个老人的脑袋砸过去并抢走他的钱包。锤子本身没有什么不好的。关键在于你如何使用它，为什么不把它用作变革的力量，用作强大而积极的力量呢？例如，如果你是一个体育用品公司品牌，难道不是很棒吗？你实际上可以成为推动消费者想要更多地锻炼、让自己为了自己和所爱的人变得更健康的内在动力。难道这不是一件好事吗？我认为这是一件好事。
America's Read is a psychologist and professor of marketing at the Wharton School at the University of Pennsylvania. When we come back, how we use the things we buy to reflect not just who we are, but what we believe in. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Nero Paharia first became interested in the psychological power of consumer products because of the diamond industry.
阿米尔·雷德是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的心理学家兼市场营销学教授。稍后回来，我们将探讨我们如何利用购买的东西不仅来反映我们是谁，还反映我们信仰什么。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。尼罗·帕哈里亚（Nero Paharia）最初对消费品的心理力量产生兴趣，是因为钻石行业。
The diamond engagement ring, how else could two-month salary last forever? A diamond. I studied economics as an undergraduate and one thing they tell you as an economics major is that people are rational. But as far as Nero could tell, there was nothing particularly rational about buying a diamond.
钻石订婚戒指，还有什么能让两个月的薪水永存？一颗钻石。我读本科时学的是经济学，经济学专业教你的一件事就是人是理性的。但就尼罗所能理解的而言，买钻石这件事绝对谈不上理性。
Now, you can argue that diamonds are beautiful, but there are cheaper stones that are just as pretty. So, then the question is, why are people spending so much money on these shiny rocks that have no intrinsic value, and you know, there's effectively a perfect substitute? And then it seemed like it was all this kind of psychological stuff that people wanted to express their status, people wanted to kind of fit in with sort of the normative practices in terms of marriage.
现在，你可以争辩说钻石很美丽，但还有更便宜的石头同样漂亮。所以，问题就在于，为什么人们要花这么多钱去买这些没有内在价值、而且你明明知道实际上存在完美替代品的闪亮石头？然后这似乎完全变成了某种心理层面的东西：人们想要彰显自己的地位，人们想要融入婚姻方面的规范做法中。
And it's just sort of dawned on me that products have all this psychological value and that's worth real money. I mean, a whole industry is based on just sort of pure kind of signaling and psychological value. And I found that to be really interesting and sort of at odds with this notion that people are rational. This idea made Nero, who's now a marketing professor at Georgetown University, think about the other ways we use money as a signaling device to express our beliefs and our values.
我突然意识到，产品具有所有的心理价值，而这是真金白银。我的意思是，整个行业都建立在纯粹的符号象征和心理价值基础之上。我觉得这非常有趣，而且与人们是理性的这一观念相矛盾。这个想法让现在是乔治城大学市场营销学教授的尼罗开始思考我们用金钱作为信号传达工具来表达信仰和价值观的其他方式。
We enact our political will usually by voting or supporting different kinds of legislations and things like that. So it's kind of interesting when people start taking that civic actions, these kind of civic actions into the market and then start bycautting or boycautting a certain brand or a certain company in order to express their view. And you can kind of think about it in terms of what ends up being more tangible. So if we think about voting, it's sort of an abstract process. It's not very public. Whereas when you buy a product or avoid buying a product, it's very tangible.
我们通常通过投票、支持各种立法之类的方式来表达我们的政治意愿。因此，当人们开始将这种公民行动、这种公民行动带入市场，并开始抵制或支持某个品牌或公司以表达他们的观点时，这就变得有点有趣了。你可以从最终什么更切实的角度来思考这个问题。如果我们想想投票，它其实是一个抽象的过程。它不是很公开。然而，当你买一件产品或避免买一件产品时，它是非常切实的。
If you're someone who doesn't buy flashy jewelry, you may say, okay, I'm not one of those people who uses money to talk. Maybe. Or maybe you just don't use diamonds to talk, you use coffee. I've studied the situations between small coffee shops and large coffee shops. And so I have a paper where we show that for a small coffee shop, if it's just sitting there by itself, people don't really think much of the political situation. They just think more about the coffee, sort of about the more rational, economic features and attributes of the product. But as soon as you put a large competitor in next door, say you put a Starbucks in next door, all of a sudden it becomes a fight between the little guy and the big guy and then buying your cup of coffee is really meaningful.
如果你是不买浮夸珠宝的人，你可能会说，好吧，我不是那种用金钱说话的人。也许吧。或者你只是不用钻石说话，你用咖啡。我研究过小咖啡馆和大咖啡馆之间的情境。所以我有篇论文表明，对于一家小咖啡馆来说，如果它只是孤零零地开在那里，人们其实不会多想政治形势。他们更多地考虑咖啡，考虑产品更理性的经济特征和属性。但一旦你在隔壁放一个大型竞争对手，比如在隔壁放一家星巴克，突然之间，这就成了小人物和大人物之间的战斗，然后你买的那杯咖啡就变得极具意义。
All of a sudden, it's a symbol of what you believe in. It's a symbol of you supporting the little guy, of you supporting the underdog and trying to stick it to the man. And it's so tangible, and I just find it so fascinating that that's sort of how we kind of express our political views on a daily basis, and we feel powerful in a sense that we actually sort of have a say in this situation. The company's of course pay attention to what consumers want. They understand that people don't just want to buy a cup of coffee or a computer, they
突然之间，它成了你信仰的象征。它是你支持小人物、支持弱者并试图给大人物一点颜色看看的象征。它是如此切实，我只觉得这太奇妙了，这就是我们日常表达政治观点的方式，我们在某种程度上感到强大，因为我们实际上对这种情况有发言权。公司当然会关注消费者的需求。他们明白人们不只是想买一杯咖啡或一台电脑，他们
want the right story to go with that cup of coffee or computer. This is why so many Silicon Valley companies that are worth billions of dollars spend so much time telling us about their origin stories, how two kids dropped out of college to explore a dream in someone's garage. So this is what we call, we have another paper around underdog brand biographies and this sort of idea of kind of starting in a garage from humble beginnings, but overcoming obstacles to kind of fulfill your dream. That's a really compelling narrative, especially to Americans. I think because of the whole kind of pull yourself up from your bootstraps and this whole notion of the American dream.
希望那杯咖啡或电脑能配上正确的故事。这就是为什么那么多价值数十亿美元的硅谷公司花那么多时间给我们讲述他们的起源故事，比如两个孩子如何从大学辍学，在某个人的车库里探索梦想。所以这就是我们所说的，我们还有另一篇关于弱者品牌传记的论文，这种从车库起步、出身卑微但克服障碍以实现梦想的想法。这是一个非常引人注目的叙事，对美国人来说尤其如此。我认为是因为那种白手起家的精神和美国梦的整个概念。
So companies that take advantage of that narrative, and if they use it effectively, even as they grow, can kind of remind consumers that this was a small company and they might identify with it more and that's penalize them less for being a large company. There tends to be sort of a kind of an aversion or a disdain for large companies. People tend to identify a lot more with smaller companies. And you tell the story of Nantucket Nectars, which also has the same sort of startup story. A lot of companies, they talk about how Nantucket Nectars, which also has the same sort of start-up story.
因此，利用这种叙事的公司，如果他们能有效地运用它，即使在他们壮大之后，也能提醒消费者这曾是一家小公司，他们可能会对它产生更多共鸣，从而因其是一家大公司而对他们少一些惩罚。人们往往对大公司有一种厌恶或鄙视。人们往往对小公司的认同感要高得多。你讲了Nantucket Nectars的故事，它也有着同样的创业故事。许多公司都在谈论Nantucket Nectars，特别是谈论它是如何起步的。
A lot of companies, they talk about how Nantucket Nectars in particular talks about how they started with a blender and a dream, and Cliff Bar talks about how they started in their garage with, he was living with his dog and his skis and cooking and it's a sort of underdog narrative that makes use of the sort of external disadvantage but really trying hard and I think people really find that story resonating because I think we all on some level feel like underdogs and so it can be motivating to us. Of course, the underdog is not the only type of brand that can draw us in. In fact, Nero has found that brands that are powerful, brands that might be seen as the opposite of the underdog, can also attract people. One example, Walmart.
很多公司，他们谈论Nantucket Nectars是如何特别提到他们如何从一台搅拌机和一个梦想开始的，而Cliff Bar谈论他们是如何在车库里开始的，当时他和他的狗还有滑雪板住在一起并做饭，这是一种弱者叙事，利用了外部劣势但非常努力，我认为人们真的发现这个故事能引起共鸣，因为我认为我们在某种程度上都觉得自己是弱者，所以这可以激励我们。当然，弱者并不是唯一能吸引我们的品牌类型。事实上，内罗发现，强大的品牌，甚至可能被视为弱者对立面的品牌，也能吸引人。一个例子就是沃尔玛。
Yeah, it's kind of interesting. So there is this relationship between status and power. And so status is a way, it's sort of what we get when we have power. And so when we think about power, we can think about warmer as being a really powerful brand. It has a lot of strength in the marketplace. And so that strength, that kind of access to power, having a lot of resources as a brand in itself, even though it's kind of a low-end brand, if you compare it to other low-end brands, that can be kind of attractive to people who care about status. Many of us understand the economic choices we make and have real ethical consequences.
是的，这挺有意思的。所以地位和权力之间存在着这种关系。地位是一种方式，是我们拥有权力时所获得的某种东西。因此，当我们考虑权力时，我们可以认为沃尔玛是一个非常强大的品牌。它在市场上有很强的力量。因此，这种力量，那种获得权力的途径，作为一个品牌本身就拥有大量资源，尽管它是一种低端品牌，如果你把它和其他低端品牌相比，这对关心地位的人来说可能很有吸引力。我们许多人都明白，我们做出的经济选择会带来真正的道德后果。
The products we buy can adversely affect the environment or take advantage of poor people in distant countries. We can buy stuff from stores that treat employees well, or we can buy things sometimes at a cheaper price from stores that treat their employees poorly. Often, after a big new story about conditions in sweatshops or the use of child labor, this public outrage. But as Nero has explored, our actions don't always match our rhetoric. She once wrote a paper on the subject title,
我们购买的产品可能会对环境产生负面影响，或者剥削遥远国家的穷人。我们可以从善待员工的商店买东西，或者有时我们可以从虐待员工的商店以更便宜的价格买东西。通常，在关于血汗工厂环境或使用童工的大新闻出现后，公众会感到愤怒。但正如内罗所探讨的那样，我们的行动并不总是与我们的言辞相符。她曾就此主题写过一篇论文，题目是
Sweatshop labor is wrong unless the shoes are cute. The idea there is that you kind of decide how much you like something, and so you really like a pair of shoes. And so then kind of the moral reasoning starts from there. It doesn't start from kind of a neutral place where you're like, where you say, oh, sweatshop labor is wrong. You know, under any circumstances, I don't want to subject people to these unfortunate working conditions. It actually starts at a place where you're like, well, the product's really
血汗工厂劳动是错误的，除非鞋子很可爱。那里的想法是，你先决定你有多喜欢某样东西，比如你真的很喜欢一双鞋。然后道德推理就从那里开始。它不是从一个中立的地方开始的，比如你会说，哦，血汗工厂劳动是错误的。你知道，在任何情况下，我都不会让人们遭受这些不幸的工作条件。它实际上从这样一个地方开始：嗯，这个产品真的很
nice. And the shoes look really good on me. And then you start reasoning about it. And that's called motivated reasoning. So rather than think about morality in terms of this kind of objective thing, we kind of think about it more like a lawyer. So we decide what we want. And then we kind of come up with the reasons to support it. So we may say, oh, if we see a pair of shoes that we don't like, we may say, oh, switch up labor is wrong. I don't like switch up labor. I don't approve. But if the shoes are cute, you might say, oh, if we see a pair of shoes that we don't like, we may say, oh, switch up labor is wrong.
好。这双鞋穿在我脚上很好看。然后你开始为它辩解。这被称为动机性推理。因此，与其用这种客观的东西来思考道德，我们更倾向于像律师那样思考。所以我们决定我们想要什么。然后我们想出各种理由来支持它。所以我们可能会说，哦，如果我们看到一双我们不喜欢鞋子，我们可能会说，哦，血汗工厂劳动是错误的。我不喜欢血汗工厂劳动。我不赞成。但如果鞋子很可爱，你可能会说，哦，如果我们看到一双我们不喜欢鞋子，我们可能会说，哦，血汗工厂劳动是错误的。
I don't like switch up labor. I don't approve. But if the shoes are cute, you might say something like, oh, it's okay because people need jobs, their companies need to make money. So you'll be more likely to agree with these things because you're motivated. In a sense, the shoes are really cute. You really want them. So you want to find a way to kind of reconcile your kind of distaste for this situation
我不喜欢血汗工厂劳动。我不赞成。但如果鞋子很可爱，你可能会说这样的话，哦，没关系，因为人们需要工作，公司需要赚钱。所以你会更有可能同意这些事情，因为你有动力。从某种意义上说，鞋子真的很可爱。你真的很想要它们。所以你想找到一种方法来调和你的这种厌恶情绪
and the kind of the reality of it. And you've actually conducted experiments which show that people are more likely to reach for these kinds of rationalizations when they actually like a product? Yes, exactly. So if they like a product, if you show them sort of an attractive pair of shoes, they'll be more likely to agree with these economic justifications. If you show them an unattractive pair of shoes, all of a sudden they become these kind of moral animals who say, oh no it's wrong. And so the idea is that we just decide what is moral based on, you know, how much we want
以及这种现实情况。你实际上做过实验，表明当人们真正喜欢某个产品时，他们更有可能使用这种合理化解释吗？是的，完全正确。因此，如果他们喜欢某个产品，如果你向他们展示一双很有吸引力的鞋子，他们就会更有可能同意这些经济上的合理化解释。如果你向他们展示一双没有吸引力的鞋子，突然之间他们就变成了那种道德动物，他们会说，哦不，这是不对的。所以这个想法是，我们只是根据我们有多想要
something. What one thing you've looked at is that we're often willing to go along with products that are ethically problematic so long as we can come up with a way to distance ourselves from the unethical behavior that produced it. The more distance we can put between ourselves and the unethical behavior or the unethical action, the easier it becomes to perform. So this goes to the idea that if I went to the grocery store and asked for a chicken and they went out and killed a chicken for me, I would feel worse about that than if I was just picking up the
某样东西来决定什么是道德的。你研究过的一件事是，只要我们能找到一种方法把自己与产生它的不道德行为保持距离，我们通常愿意接受在道德上有问题的产品。我们与不道德行为或不道德行动之间的距离越远，执行起来就越容易。这就好比，如果我去杂货店要一只鸡，他们出去为我杀了一只鸡，我会比仅仅从托盘里拿起
chicken from a tray. And of course, in both cases, a chicken had to be killed. But in one case, I feel like I have actually asked for the chicken to be killed. In the other case, the dirty walk has already been done. Yeah. So there's a number of things that sort of enable us to not feel so close to the harm. I mean, essentially, you're buying a product from a company, but what you're doing is you're hiring them to do kind of this dirty work for you.
鸡感觉更糟糕。当然，在这两种情况下，都必须有一只鸡被杀。但在一种情况下，我觉得我实际上要求杀这只鸡。而在另一种情况下，脏活已经干完了。是的。因此，有很多事情让我们觉得离伤害没有那么近。我的意思是，从本质上讲，你是从一家公司买产品，但你实际上是在雇佣他们为你做这种脏活。
So say any clothing company, they're the ones who hire a child and maybe, you know, under some unfortunate conditions, you're not directly actually hiring that person. But I think the second thing that happens is this idea of the order of how kind of supply and demand happens. So we live in an economy where most items are produced first. And so they're already produced, they're already in the store. And so when you go to the store, the damage has been done.
所以假设任何服装公司，他们才是雇佣童工的人，也许在一些不幸的条件下，你并没有直接雇佣那个人。但我认为发生的第二件事是关于供求关系发生顺序的概念。所以我们生活在一个大多数物品都是先生产出来的经济体中。因此它们已经被生产出来了，它们已经在商店里了。所以当你去商店时，损害已经造成了。
So to speak. So it's already been done, it's already happened. But imagine that you go to the store, the damage has been done. So to speak. So it's already been done. It's already happened. But imagine that you went into that same store and you had to order your chicken or your clothes on demand. So if you order it on demand, they then they will put a child have them work under these unfortunate conditions and then you start feeling responsible and guilty for this situation where when it's already happened you feel like oh well it's already happened and I'm not responsible for it and I think people don't really kind of see this broader role that consumers have in creating demand for these kinds of products. They don't see that a causes b
可以这么说。所以它已经完成了，已经发生了。但想象一下，你走进同一家商店，你必须按需点你的鸡肉或衣服。因此，如果你按需求点餐，那么他们就会让一个孩子在这些不幸的条件下工作，然后你开始对这种情况感到责任感和内疚感，而当它已经发生时，你会觉得，哦，好吧，它已经发生了，我对此不负责任，我认为人们并没有真正看到消费者在为这些产品创造需求方面所发挥的更广泛的作用。他们没有看到a导致了b
because it sort of happens backwards, that they actually make the product first, and then you decide if you want it. But if we lived in an economy that was all on demand, then it would happen the other way. You would decide you want it, and then they would make it, and then there would be a stronger connection, kind of a stronger cause-and-effect connection, that I think people would then feel a bit more responsible and a bit more guilty for these kinds of situations. I can imagine that people would feel horrible if they said I want a shirt and they have to send some poor nine-year-old kid into the basement to make the shirt for the next six hours.
因为它是倒着发生的，他们实际上先生产产品，然后你决定是否想要它。但如果我们生活在一个全按需生产的经济体中，那么情况就会反过来。你决定你想要它，然后他们制造它，然后就会产生更强的联系，一种更强的因果联系，我想人们就会对这种情况感到更多的责任感和负罪感。我可以想象，如果人们说我想要一件衬衫，而他们不得不派一个可怜的九岁小孩去地下室在接下来的六个小时里为他们做这件衬衫，他们会感觉糟糕透了。
I mean, people would feel awful about that. Yeah, and I think people wouldn't do it. And so then it kind of gets to this question of, does the economic structure and the structure of how goods are made, does the kind of logistical structure impact how we think about ethics and how we think about our own role in enabling these kinds of harms? The companies who make stuff for us are run by people, and those people have minds that work
我的意思是，人们对此会感觉很糟糕。是的，我想人们不会那样做。这就引出了这样一个问题：经济结构和货物的制造结构，这种物流结构是否会影响我们对道德的思考，以及我们如何看待自己助长这些危害的角色？为我们制造东西的公司是由人经营的，而这些人的思想运作方式
like our minds. So should Cummins no surprise that just as consumers would rather have companies do the dirty work for them, to distance themselves from the ethical consequences of their economic actions, companies often choose to do exactly the same thing. Rather than run a factory that makes clothing under offer working conditions, why not outsource the dirty work to someone else? If a reporter units details of poor working conditions, you can now plausibly say, but I didn't know about it. In many cases, companies actually do outsource the harm,
和我们的思想一样。因此，正如消费者宁愿让公司为他们干脏活，以将自己与经济行为的道德后果隔离开来一样，公司也常常选择完全这样做，这也就不足为奇了。与其经营一家在恶劣工作条件下制造服装的工厂，为什么不把脏活外包给别人呢？如果记者详细报道了糟糕的工作条件，你现在就可以貌似有理地说，但我不知道这件事。在许多情况下，公司确实将危害外包出去了，
so rather than own the factory that makes the clothing under these terrible conditions, we outsource them to other firms that are owned by other entities. So a lot of these companies do try and claim that they had no knowledge of this, this did not happen within the boundaries of my firm. It turns out that both individuals and companies often prefer to be kept in the dark about unethical practices that are further up the supply chain. So there was a really, really interesting paper by Julie Irwin and some other colleagues who wrote a paper on
所以与其拥有在这些糟糕条件下制造服装的工厂，我们把它们外包给由其他实体拥有的其他公司。因此，许多这样的公司确实试图声称他们对此一无所知，这并没有在我公司的范围内发生。事实证明，个人和公司往往都愿意对供应链上游的不道德做法保持蒙昧。朱莉·欧文（Julie Irwin）和一些其他同事写了一篇非常非常有趣的论文，探讨了
this idea of willful ignorance. And the idea was that you had a product and you had access to a whole bunch of different pieces of information. And one of them was the labor conditions or the environmental conditions. And the question was, do people actually ask for this information? You can look at it if you want, but you could decide not to look at it. And it turns out people didn't want to look at that information because they didn't really want to be confronted with this kind of conflict between their beliefs and what they really wanted.
这种故意无知的想法。这个想法是，你有一个产品，你可以获得一大堆不同的信息。其中之一就是劳动条件或环境条件。问题是，人们真的会索取这些信息吗？如果你想的话你可以看，但你可以决定不看。事实证明，人们不想看这些信息，因为他们真的不想面对这种信念与他们真正想要的东西之间的冲突。
And they found this effect was stronger for people who cared more about labor issues, who cared more about environmental issues. They were more likely to avoid this information and order to kind of avoid this conflict. Think of the deep irony of what Nero just said. The folks who care the most about ethics might be most willing to turn a blind eye to unethical business practices because they know if they found out about those practices, they would feel obliged to do something about it. We've talked about the many ways in which consumers and companies play games with one another,
他们发现，对于那些更关心劳工问题、更关心环境问题的人来说，这种效应更强。为了避免这种冲突，他们更有可能避开这些信息。想想内罗刚刚所说的话中蕴含的深刻讽刺。最关心道德的人可能最愿意对不道德的商业行为视而不见，因为他们知道，如果他们发现了这些实践，他们就会觉得有义务去做点什么。我们已经讨论了消费者和公司相互博弈的多种方式，
using products to speak on their behalf or using products behind which they can hide. But there's one dimension of economic activity we haven't explored, and that's time. I asked Nero how some of us use our calendars to broadcast our social status. It used to be that people once broadcast their social status by being idle, but that idea has been turned on its head in the United States. It turns out nowadays that people who are busier actually seem to have more social status. So rather than somebody who is very wealthy, who could waste their time, take fancy vacations,
利用产品为自己代言，或者利用产品把自己藏在它们后面。但经济活动中还有一个我们尚未探讨的维度，那就是时间。我问内罗，我们中的一些人是如何利用日程表来宣示我们的社会地位的。过去，人们曾通过无所事事来宣示自己的社会地位，但在美国，这种观念已经颠覆了。事实证明，如今那些更忙碌的人似乎拥有更高的社会地位。因此，与那些非常富有、可以浪费时间、去豪华度假的人相比，
invest in learning these kind of archaic mannerisms. It turns out the person who works really hard, who's really busy, who's very effortful, is the one who's seen to have more social status. And I think in part, that is because we live in a society that values social mobility. So we actually conducted the study in the US and we conducted the same study in Italy. And we found that for Italian people they thought the person who was living a life of leisure had more status. Of course they have so much money they can just relax all the time. Whereas in the US they thought the person who was working all the time actually had more status and I think what was going
投资于学习这种古怪的礼仪。事实证明，工作非常努力、非常忙碌、付出很多努力的人，才被认为拥有更高的社会地位。我认为部分原因是因为我们生活在一个重视社会流动的社会中。所以我们实际上在美国做了一项研究，并在意大利做了同样的研究所。我们发现，对于意大利人来说，他们认为过着悠闲生活的人拥有更高的地位。当然，他们有那么多钱，所以他们可以一直放松。而在美国，他们认为一直工作的人实际上拥有更高的地位，我认为这是
on was that in the US people sort of value this sense of earned status. So status can be earned in the US where I think in Italy it's more of a society where status is inherited. So for example, my co-author is Italian and she's always talking about how people come from good families or not. And so there's very much this idea that your status isn't necessarily something that you earn but you inherit. And so in that sense, working hard really wouldn't get you anywhere,
因为在美国，人们某种程度上重视这种通过努力获得的地位。所以在美利坚地位是可以靠努力获得的，而在意大利我认为那是一个地位是继承的社会。例如，我的合著者是意大利人，她总是谈论人们是否出身名门。因此，这种观念非常强烈，即你的地位不一定是靠自己挣来的，而是继承来的。从这个意义上说，努力工作真的不会让你有任何进展，
whereas in America you have the sense that you can actually climb the ladder. And so celebrities, for example, might say instead of saying, I make one movie every year and I get to hang out on the beach for the other 10 months of the year, they actually are suggesting, oh my god, I'm so overworked. Yeah, so we actually looked at tweets of celebrities who were tagged with this hashtag humble brag, this idea of bragging, but sort of disguising it
而在美国，你有一种你可以真正向上爬的感觉。因此，例如，名人可能会说，与其说我每年拍一部电影，其余10个月都在海滩上闲逛，不如他们实际上在暗示，哦天哪，我太累了。是的，所以我们实际上查看了被贴上“谦虚的炫耀”（humble brag）标签的名人的推文，这种炫耀的想法，但将其伪装成
as a complaint. And a lot of the tweets we found had to do with being busy. So I have to be in the recording studio this morning, and then I have a book meeting in the afternoon, and then I have to travel to New York in the evening and hashtag I have no life, you know, these kinds of tweets, you're trying to say something about yourself, you're busy, you're really important.
抱怨。我们发现很多推文都与忙碌有关。比如我今天早上必须去录音室，下午要开一个图书会议，晚上还得去纽约，话题标签我没有生活，你知道，诸如此类的推文，你试图表达关于你自己的某些事情，你很忙，你真的很重要。
You don't have time to do other things and so you see that on social media that's kind of an acceptable and effective way to show your status by telling people how busy you are. Nero Paharia is a marketing professor at Georgetown University. Nero, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick.
你没有时间做其他事情，所以你在社交媒体上看到，这是一种可以接受且有效的通过告诉别人你有多忙来展示你地位的方式。内罗·帕哈里亚（Nero Paharia）是乔治etown大学的市场营销教授。内罗，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。本节目由《隐藏的大脑》传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保尔（Annie Murphy-Paul）、劳拉·夸雷勒（Laura Quarelle）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Drew Dagle. Drew is a senior ad operation specialist at Stitcher. Drew recently became the person to oversee all of the coordination involved in the production process for the ads you hear on this program. It's complicated and vitally important work, and Drew is really helping to keep that work organized and streamlined for us. Thank you, Drew. If you like Hidden Brain, you can help us make the show by making a financial contribution.
塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是德鲁·代格尔（Drew Dagle）。德鲁是Stitcher的高级广告运营专家。德鲁最近负责监督该节目中听到的广告制作流程中涉及的所有协调工作。这是一项复杂且至关重要工作，德鲁确实在帮助我们保持这项工作的组织性和精简性。谢谢你，德鲁。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，你可以通过经济捐助来帮助我们制作节目。
Just go to support.hiddenbrain.org. That side again is support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
只需访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。网址再重复一遍，support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦达姆坦（Shankar Vedantam）。我们很快再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。